i know you i know this guy you damien  are you jeremy davis dude my little  sister loves you  that's a long time ago now hey hey  you can't fail if you don't try  the show ended five years ago i'm sick  of it  it's time to work i'm gonna play i need  to get on stage the three of you  need to really have a long hard look  themselves you're gonna start losing  your friends starting with me  maybe being 30 is just slowly realizing  that you don't know anything  are you doing coaching my engagement  party  for you seth and jeremy have is very  special  so hang on to that i can't carry him  anymore when i'm getting nothing back  and are you prepared to lose her bro  [Music]